The joe rogan experience,
the neuroscience stuff is
like my bread and butter.
That's what I love.
And that is the holy grail of neurosis.
So when you hear like Depok show pro
type dudes talk about consciousness,
my eyes rolling like Deepak Chopra,
I just,
it's really hard for me to not
just discount everything he says.
Really.
I reason it's,
I mean,
I know that there's truth there,
but he is,
he's a whoop peddler
Chopra,
um,
uh,
Eckhart.
Totally.
Terry Robbins,
is that his name?
Greg Fitzsimmons loves ECKART.
Toley he's probably the least
hook story of all of them,
but he's still,
well,
what,
what do you think is huckster worry
about providing motivation to people and
giving people sort of a
framework to work on as far as,
uh,
living in the now and
taking charge of their life,
especially if it's something that
someone like Eckhart Toley had personal
success.
We'll compare somebody like at cart.
Totally to robins.
Yeah.
Compare and Eckhart totally.
Or an Anthony Robbins to,
for example,
somebody like,
um,
oh,
what's his name?
I was able to,
God,
no,
I was able to interview a,
this,
this really interesting guy who has a phd
in molecular genetics and then move to
the Himalayas to become a Buddhist monk.
Um,
his name is Matthew Ricard and he's,
he's a French Buddhist monk and he talks
about mindfulness meditation and he
talks about the neuroscience of the
things that the Tibetans are doing right
now,
but he's not trying to
make money off of it.
And I think that is a fundamental
kind of red flag for me.
I'm not saying just because
somebody is trying to make money,
they are selling snake oil.
Right.
But first of all,
what's the motivation that,
that that has to be the first red flag.
And then you go into,
what is it that they're
saying if they're talking,
if they're trying to use science and
they're trying to kind of go in and pick
and choose the science that
tells the story the right way,
and then they're making these really
broad a leaps from that science.
It makes me nervous.
So it's,
it's one thing if you've got like a
motivational speaker who's just like,
I know this about the world and
I'm not basing it on anything,
but if you like me to come follow me.
And it's like,
yeah,
that's fine.
I mean,
what is that?
That's like culty behavior,
but that's fine.
But when people pick and choose how they
want to use science and how they want
to bastardize science to meet their needs,
it makes me nervous.
I did a piece recently about
the power of positive thinking.
Um,
I've also done a piece about the
power of prayer and I went through the
literature and I tried to find examples
where positive thinking actually helped
people.
And there's just no good evidence that
thinking positively is going to actually
bring goodwill to your life.
Like the secret,
you know this like,
well,
if I just want it bad enough,
I'm going to make a bunch of money.
It's like,
no,
if you want it bad enough,
you're going to have
to fucking work for it.
And then it's gonna come to you.
And actually they find that the power of
positive thinking can actually be kind
of detrimental to cancer patients because
it causes a whole extra layer of guilt
to the process of dying.
You know,
you caused this to yourself
because you didn't,
you didn't think positively enough,
you didn't will yourself out of this.
And there's a whole culture around that
in America where we kind of blame the
victims and where we
call cancer survivors,
survivors,
and we call cancer victims victims,
you know,
and it's like,
and you're not doing so well.
Nobody says it directly to
somebody who was dying of cancer.
Well you didn't will yourself out of it,
but they feel that because they say it
indirectly to the people who are coming
out of it.
Oh,
it was all that nice prayer and all those
positive thoughts and all those Oprah
magazines you read.
You know,
and it's like,
I don't know.
I think that's a bad precedent to set.
It's also shitty science
because if you're,
you know,
you're only looking at the
group that was successful.
Well,
not all the people that died.
And that's the thing.
I tried to look at a lot of those
studies and I tried to compare,
you know,
and and I found enough stuff out there
that kind of shows that the power of
positive thinking is not a real thing.
Also,
prayer is not a real thing.
Disagree to the power of positive
thinking is not a real thing.
I think it's a good way to operate and
live your life in a happy manner will
probably lend you to
being more successful.
You'll have less hurdles.
It's like it's like talking about Karma,
you know like in some sense Karma is
totally real because if you're a fucking
nice person and you're just,
you,
you do goodwill all of the time,
sometimes shitty things
are going to happen to you,
but most people are going
to be nice to you too.
If you put bad Karma out there.
To me what that really means is if you're
just a fucking asshole all the time,
people are going to be
an asshole back to you.
Like,
that's obvious,
but I don't believe that Karma is some
sort of cosmic force that says you,
you store up goodwill with the universe
and then the universe pays you back.
Try Monday Joe Rogan podcast.
Well,
the last time you were here you coined
grace,
or you used a phrase that I have stolen
and abused over and over and over again.
I'll give you credit,
but it's Wu peddler.
Oh Yeah,
love that box show pro.
Yeah.
I definitely didn't coin that,
but I love it too.
I use a lot.
Every time I see that dude,
I just think Wu peddler have a little
kind of Twitter thing with him.
I was calling him,
I asked if he whooped
pedaled much like I am a god.
And you were like [inaudible].
And he was like,
oh,
it was really funny.
I favorite at it,
but he was actually like,
he was,
he had a good sense of humor about it.
I don't think he takes
himself totally seriously.
Seriously.
I think he gets,
he gets ahead of himself and he
said some really ridiculous shit.
And then when people call them on it,
you know,
he just starts using the word quantum.
Quantum consciousness is know I think
better him than a lot of other people in
his position better him.
Then you know that Kevin
Trudeau guy that's selling
you weight loss secrets that
they don't want you to know about.
You know what I mean?
It doesn't seem like depot
Deepak's trying to sell his books,
but outside of that I don't
really feel like he that much of,
you know,
like a Predator,
like he's not using this kind of pseudo
science and truth be told there is a
little bit of truth to some of
the things that he talks about,
but,
but he does kind of,
I think step way outside of the boundaries
of what's reasonable and healthy.
But you're right,
I don't think he's actually trying to
take advantage of people fundamentally.
I think that Deepak Chopra
thinks what he's talking about.
I mean he believes in what he's talking
about and I think that he actually
thinks that he's helping people
and maybe it's helping some people,
but he's also peddling a lot of woo.
I think,
I think he probably is helping a lot.
I think he's definitely
peddling a lot of woo.
And the one thing that I always get out
of him is that I don't think even he
knows what he's saying.
I think there's a lot of times where
people will try to impress upon you that
what they're saying is important.
And one of the ways they do that is by
using these like really kind of like
vague terms.
That sound fantastic.
Yeah.
I mean that's really,
I think where that term
pseudoscience comes from.
It's not real science,
it's,
it's fake science,
it's bad science.
But it sorta sounds like
science to an untrained ear.
And that's the dangerous thing is if you
throw around a lot of really big words
and you are really authoritative,
a lot of people kind of believe
what you're telling them.
What also do
that.
Some of it does have some truth to it.
And when you fuck around
and pretend that it all does
mush it altogether,
you,
you create this really cloudy atmosphere.
Well,
I'm under,
I'm not sure what the fuck you're saying.
And I'm not sure if it's true,
but it's really hard for like
an everyday person who goes,
okay,
well I've heard that before and you know,
my doctor told me that and you know,
that seems important.
And then they throw in all
these other things will,
I mean if you're an authority figure and
you're saying all these things that are
true,
I guess I should believe you.
And you say all these other things,
it's a really dangerous,
um,
you know,
that's it,
right?
It says,
I was an atheist Hashtag
until I discovered I was God.
And then I said,
son,
don't make me smack you woo pedal.
Yeah,
much.
And then he responded,
he responded something really funny.
I don't know if you can find it.
Yeah.
Like I roll God in drag.
That actually is very fun.
It's like,
oh,
that's pretty awesome.
Well,
you know,
he did a thing with his son where his
son of followed him around with a camera
and completely exposed
him and he went on tour,
like promoted this with his son and did
like interviews on like opie and Anthony
and all these different places.
But one of them was like his son,
like caught him sleeping when he
was supposed to be meditating.
I'm going to the temple to meditate.
I mean,
they go into the temple,
he's,
he's completely out cold line.
I his back and it's,
it's,
it's quite funny because his son sort of,
you know,
grew up with him and his sons and
fathers have notoriously contentious
relationships.
I'm always incredibly impressed when I
meet a daughter who gets along great with
her mom or a son who gets along great
with his dad because somewhere along the
line and those male,
male,
female,
female relationships that seems to
be this like changing of the guard or
something like that or this
need to be your own person.
And [inaudible] son has
that shit in buckets,
buckets full of that.
And it's cool that Deepak doesn't
really take himself too seriously.
He,
you know,
his son catches him asleep and he's like,
yeah,
but
I was not called,
I was traveling.
It was aware of,
I was,
my third eye was open
to the possibilities.
Yeah.
He did a,
uh,
an interview or a debate rather with
Richard Dawkins fairly recently on,
I think it was,
he was challenging Dawkins on the
concept of atheism and you know,
and Dawkins was just being
as cadre old country settled,
but it actually made it actually
made him Dawkins look bad.
And I mean that's the thing,
it's,
it's when you engage in those kinds of
conversations with people who can really
hold their own,
you've gotta be really
careful because Dawkins,
I think he's taking,
and I respect the man immensely.
His take is very much an educated,
you know,
I'm an evolutionist,
I'm an evolutionary biologist.
These are the reasons that
I don't believe in God,
but he's very hard lined about it.
And there is something about
being this kind of ivory tower,
British elite that just kind
of makes you seem like a dick.
Even like he's not a dick.
He's a really sweet man.
I've met him before.
He's,
he's soft spoken.
But the truth is you,
you put those two men in a room together,
Depok knows what he's doing.
He knows that like part of a debate
or part of the conversation is about
bringing out certain aspects
of somebody's character.
It's about likability.
And I think it's easy for people who
aren't already kind of hard lined atheist
and who aren't already big
dock and supporters to be like,
that guy seems mean.
Well,
I think he is mean.
I disagree with you.
I think he is a dick
and I think he is mean.
And I think um,
that's because he's had to deal with
idiots over and over and over again.
And he's an extremely intelligent man
and he's tired of it and it gets this
quivering and his lips,
when he talks to people,
you know,
no,
that is not what's going on.
He gets so furious about defending
science and defending the truth.
I don't think he's a
dick in an unjust way.
And he's a Dick for a reason.
He's a Dick because he's a normal guy.
I think he's also a dick because he's a
normal guy with a lot of knowledge that
doesn't have a lot of
release in his life probably.
And he's also,
I think he's also sheltered a little
bit because of his position because of,
you know,
when you work in academia and you're
kind of surrounded by likeminded people a
lot and only periodically do you go out
into the real world where there's a lot
of people who don't have the education
that you have and who have totally
different values and belief systems.
I'm sure it can be really,
really frustrating because
you're constantly having
to defend a position that's
the rational that like anybody else
who's come up through the ranks that you
came up,
uh,
you know,
97% of practicing scientists or
something like that don't believe in God.
And maybe it's not that high,
but 97% definitely,
you know,
know that global warming is true.
And maybe
it's something like 75% in
America don't believe in God,
but we're like a very religious country.
But when you kind of go through the
motions and you just come to these logical
conclusions because of all of the
different life choices you've made,
but then you interact with people who
are from such different backgrounds,
who have never studied evolution,
who have never studied,
you know,
global climate change or whatever.
It's like talking to a wall sometimes
because you almost can't have the same
kind of reasonable conversations because
when you're talking to somebody who's
not coming from a rational
evidence based place,
who's coming from kind of appeals to
emotion or who's coming from folklore or
whatever reason,
they have to defend their
kind of belief structure,
their faith position.
It's really frustrating because you don't
really have a lot of ammunition at a
certain point,
but especially when you're talking to
somebody like Deepak Chopra who has like
made a career kind of
being good at debating,
who knows exactly the way to twist your
words and to make it sound like what
he's speaking is the truth.
And then he's got this like
very benevolent kind of
kind and calm demeanor and
he's going to make
Dawkins look like a dick.
Oh,
see,
I didn't think that he did any,
any twisting them.
Any words at all?
Oh really?
No,
no.
I think,
you know,
he seemed like a woo peddler.
I mean,
to use your term,
he,
that's what he seemed like.
But Dawkins was just getting so
angry and it's that old saying,
you know,
never argue with an idiot,
cause people won't be
able to tell who's who.
That's not the same.
I don't know how it works for me.
I would never,
like,
I would never debate a creation.
It's like people say,
Oh,
you should blah,
blah,
blah.
And I think like Bill Nye,
I dunno if it's happened yet,
but they'll nice of us to debate Ken Ham.
That's insane.
I don't know why he's doing it.
I mean,
I have friends,
you know,
I'm friends with Sean Carroll,
who's a physicist at Caltech and
writes these really great books about,
about time and about,
um,
uh,
quantum physics.
And he does periodically
debate creationists.
And I'm always like,
what are you doing that's,
that's like such a bad idea.
You know,
like,
because these people are skilled
just in the art of conversation.
They're skilled in the art of debate.
Even if what they're saying has no weight,
they know how to argue these positions
and try and trap you and get you on the
defensive.
They have all of these
different kind of uh,
uh,
skillsets,
but he always says,
it's not for me.
It's not to try and prove him wrong.
It's not to try and convince
him not to believe in God.
You know,
like this guy is it.
Ken Ham is like a hardcore
fundamentalist Christian.
We're never going to change his mind.
So they say the reason that we do
these debates is for the people who are
sitting there watching who may be like,
Ooh,
I don't know the difference between
evolution and intelligent design.
I've never thought about it.
I've never really looked at the evidence
that may be even a small percentage of
the people who decide to tune in.
We'll be given some sort of information
that they didn't have before that they
can be armed with to
make better decisions.
But I don't know.
To me it just seems like,
I mean I think it's a noble pursuit,
but at the same time,
I'm not sure how effective it
really is to debate a creationist.
I say I disagree with you.
I think it's,
I don't think you're going
to convince the creationist.
No,
not at all.
But I do think that there's,
there's value in someone who's good at it.
If someone has the ability to speak and
speak well and also they have to have a
certain amount of charisma.
And the issue,
the Dawkins issue is that he gets so
emotionally invested in this fucking
horseshit that Depok spewing that he
gets angry and furious instead of mocking
him.
Like there's a brilliant exchange with a,
there was a scientist,
there was a,
a,
a panel and Deepak was
on the panel and this,
this,
uh,
scientists stepped up and,
ask Depok a question and Eh,
Depok clearly didn't know what
the fuck he was talking about.
But the way the guy handled it was very
sweet and he was smiling while he did
explain that he was in the process of
writing a book with Stephen Hawkings and
then he was in the middle of
this and then that I don't,
he's like,
I understand those words you said,
but uh,
I'm not sure if they mean anything.
The way he said it was,
it was adorable.
Like,
cause the guy didn't lose his cool and
it made Depok look like a fucking idiot.
Where's it at?
The same guy got up and said,
you know,
what is this quantum talk?
You're talking a bunch of fucking
bullshit and shut up and you don't know.
Then all of a sudden,
you know,
Deepak is this pudgy Indian
man that you're picking up
the screams of racism and
all this other fucking
hot buttons get pushed.
And I think the same thing can be
done skillfully with these creationist
fellows.
Like shy.
I think the idea behind creationism is
so preposterous that in the form that we
see it in the form of,
you know,
not,
not in the form of something
created the universe,
whether it's some sort of a universal
force that creates stars or the reason why
Adam's exists in the first place.
All these like fundamental questions
that scientists have as to why the
structure of the universe is what it is.
There's that,
but then there's this book that has been
translated from other books and then
they're sticking to
this fucking crazy book.
Just point out the other shit
in the book that's ridiculous.
Like the shit in the book about not being
on the word to deploy different types
types of cloth.
And they do that.
Usually they'll point
out the shit in the book.
That's ridiculous.
And they figure out,
you know,
and point out how,
if the book says this,
you truly believe this in this century
and science has unequivocally disproven
what it is that you believe.
You know,
it's one thing to talk about,
like you said,
uh,
you know,
these big questions like what came before
the Big Bang or you know what a lot
of,
I feel like I'm intelligent
design advocates confused,
for example,
evolution via natural
selection with a a biogenesis.
So they confuse the idea of
how a organisms have evolved
over time with how life
began in the first place,
which is a fundamentally
different scientific question,
different topic,
totally different field of inquiry.
And so,
you know,
a lot of times what they do is
they appeal to these two questions.
They say like,
well,
you don't know what existed
before the Big Bang,
therefore God done Mike Drop,
you know,
every time.
And instead of kind
of allowing that,
it's to say,
you know,
okay,
neither of us know why.
Why has God the,
the first,
you know,
answer that you jumped to,
let's look at all the other times when
you're saying that the answer is God and
we've disproven it over
and over and over and over.
And just because we don't have all of
the answers to every question right now
using the scientific
method doesn't mean that,
you know,
through through new tools,
through new lines of inquiry that we
might be able to answer those in the
future.
It doesn't mean that like,
just because we don't have,
that doesn't mean that there aren't
other philosophical answers to these
questions that don't rely on this
like very fundamentalist view.
I think personally that for example,
Bill Nye is going to be
able to hold his own.
He's a total bad ass.
He's not going to lose
his cool and Ken Ham,
if you've ever watched him in PE,
I mean he's a nut job.
Like he's a total pull up some videos,
he's a total nutter butter and he will
lose his cool and he's totally not
likable like nothing about this guy.
He's likable.
So I think that maybe that's why bill and
I was willing to do it cause I've seen
Bill Nye,
right?
Go on like Bill O'reilly a million times
and there's kind of a mutual respect
there.
He,
he deals with bill O'Reilly very well,
and I'm always impressed.
And just one,
one is the tide comes in.
Yeah.
You can't explain that.
Yeah,
he was with Steve.
Yeah.
And he's,
it was so fucking funny.
Such a face balm.